unfortunately after eight videos we've
run out of tips nah who am i kidding
i've got more for you you know what to
do if you enjoy our series here on
gamespot hit that like button we
appreciate it we've got some more
goodies for you today so here we go
dubious food is often not very useful
recovering only a quarter of a heart may
be one heart at most but hearty lizards
ignore this rule and if you cook five of
them it actually makes a meal that's not
completely terrible healing up a
whopping 20 hearts
quince is a pretty interesting npc he's
one of the few hylians outside of gerudo
desert who actually reacts differently
to your gerudo outfit as he'll hit on
you for a second until he realizes that
you're a guy
another interesting fact is that his dog
is the only named dog that we know of in
the entire game his name is sadie and
you should talk to quince to hear a
story about how they met it's very
wholesome you may have heard of the term
smuggling before a way for link to hold
things he's not supposed to what you
might not know is how many ways to
smuggle have been found so far with
common ones such as weapon and bow
smuggling but even more such as shield
bomb arrow
item hold
and item lift smuggling
along with arrow smuggling people have
found one of the wildest visual and
audio bugs in the game called active
aero smuggling it does this
there's a hidden move that's fairly
dangerous to pull off in combat because
of its long animation called hop back
striking you may have done it by
accident before by holding zl then
pressing attack and backflip at the same
time you'll do a special hop back then
auto jump attack but this can be used to
weirdly weave right through the entirety
of a sword lynel's triple slash attack
did you know that stalnock's eyes can be
transferred between each other by
stealing one eyeball then carrying it to
another stylenox knocking out their eye
will cause that stylenox to pick up the
closest eyeball to it even if it's one
of its neighbor's eyeballs
also stonewalks have friendly fire on
against their own eyes and can damage
themselves while stomping killing
themselves for you not the sharpest tool
in the shed as they say
you need 4 bundles of wood to create an
updraft but you only need three of the
campfires to keep the updraft
and did you know a burning wood fence or
spike can substitute as one campfire
each when fueling an updraft
also preset campfires are different from
your normal campfire unlike a normal
campfire they still stay lit after
resting
[Music]
if you place an octo balloon at the very
tip of a weapon then wait for it to
float upright then cut off the balloon
string you can make the weapons stay
completely vertical on their own
whenever you want
and yes everyone knows about that
guardian scout spear that stays upright
too but did you also know that enemies
need to reach the handle of the weapon
in order to pick it up if weapons are
flipped right side up enemies can grab
them just fine but if they're flipped
upside down the handle is too high for
them to reach
[Music]
there's a group of friends at the gerudo
horse stables whose names are sesame
olive flaxsell canola and palm these are
of course a reference to real world oils
sesame olive flax canola and palm oil if
you watch closely you can catch crabs
doing a cute little dance i swear i hear
something in the background
all of the basic horse equipment in the
game is made by epona company serving
hyrule for more than 150 years their
logo can be seen on the sanidine park
ruins statue
any longtime zelda player knows of the
infamous enemy bemos who are known for
their robot eyes that shoot lasers at
link but did you know they're actually
in breath of the wild unfortunately it's
just this thing right here yeah not the
most exciting thing but it is cool to
know that the vmos is technically and
officially in the game for people who
aren't too versed in the speedrunning
community there are some really um
interesting category extensions for
breath of the wild also known as meme
runs such as monkey percent where you
eat a banana as fast as possible after
hearing a monkey in the jungle
throwing a rake in the lake as fast as
possible and my personal favorite run
butt a dog dog with the butter on him
percent with the goal of putting butter
on a dog as fast as possible yes these
are real and yes there are leaderboards
for them the rocks strewn around the
master sword pedestal aren't just for
decoration each rock represents
something the main three corners of the
triforce represent the goddesses of
hyrule din nehru and theyore the rocks
on the outer ring represent the gerudo
hylians zora shika kokiri and the goron
races regular chuchu jellies have a
secret property you may not have noticed
they actually have a small physical
splash that's not present in any of the
elemental versions
this mechanic is amplified during dash
attacks to launch yourself into the air
and get bullet time called jelly
bouncing
this is not exclusive to link though
while there are many ways to push and
launch enemies in breath of the wild
there hasn't been a way to forcefully
launch a lynel and no its jumping attack
doesn't count well a way to launch
lynels has finally been found by using
one tiny choo choo jelly
have you ever seen a whiz robe without
his cloak on well here you go you're
welcome enjoy your nightmares keys can
be distracted by noises just like any
other enemy arrow shots and bombs will
attract them
oil lanterns from the bakoblin skull
camps can be torn down and saved but
they are extremely fragile it's also
possible to put out the fire and
reignite it as long as you don't hit it
directly
some players may already know about a
visual glitch that removes cell shading
to show the lower plastic shaders in
breath of the wild such as the popular
one at the bridge of hylia and other
places but these were always very
limited in their angles and their space
to move around but if you glitch into
the spring of courage early the mossy
skin around the non-existing shrine
gives you the biggest plastic shader in
the game and you can do and see many
things without cell shading this meat
looks very
rubbery
if you're a newer player and are a bit
intimidated by all the advanced launch
techniques out there i've got an easy
one for you if you find any wooden box
out in the overworld put a square bomb
on one corner of the box then stand on
the opposite corner then simply detonate
the bomb this is called a kibako launch
also known as a wooden box launch
enemies with wooden shields can block
shock arrows easily but there's a nifty
trick that you could still pull off with
shock arrows if you shoot the ground in
front of the enemy with a shock arrow
they're able to still conduct and shock
enemies directly from the ground without
needing to shoot them directly
here's a bonus fun fact about my outfit
since 2017 most people who have followed
me think this clothing set is based off
of assassin's creed protagonist altair
but it's actually inspired by my main
character and color set in blazblue
kawkaka
and that's a wrap if you continue to
enjoy this series check out a breath of
the wild expert series playlist with
tons of breath of the wild tidbits that
you never knew about and for everything
else gaming stay tuned right here on
gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
you